[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANANT JHINGRAN:
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Anant Jhingran.
I used to be the CTO for
a company called Apigee
that some of you might know.
We helped some of you, or
many of you, with APIs.
But I've actually dabbled in
data analytics and machine
learning and other things longer
than some of you, at least,
have been on this planet Earth.
So it's a fantastic
thought process
to see what's really
going to happen
or what's really happening when
these two forces come together.
And what we'll also do is bring
all of these topics and things
and discussions that
I kind of bring about
by bringing a customer over,
Jason Smith from rMark Bio,
who's going to talk
about how he and his team
bring the power of
AI and API together.
So if you're ready for
the journey, let's go.
I'm a very peripatetic
individual,
so my biggest fear is I'll fall.
And so if you see me
come close to the edge,
just start screaming
and that'll be good.
OK.
So this is the duality that
we're going to discuss.
Keep it at a high level.
I'm a nerd, a geek,
a technologist.
But what I want to do
is that for all of you
to leave here today and
understand that these two most
powerful trends
that are happening
in the digital economy
actually have a very, very
symbiotic relationship.
And what I want to do
is kind of just get
all of you to get
comfortable with
that symbiotic relationship.
So in order to begin,
I thought that kind
of building upon what Fei-Fei
talked about yesterday, just
give you folks a bit of
perspective on the AI journey
that has happened, and
kind of contrast it
with a couple of other
things that are going on.
Now, AI, of course, has been
thought about for a long time
as something that can
act, pass a Turing test,
and act and think
like a human being.
Now of course, for those of you
who know, the test by itself
is sometimes easy to pass
and sometimes difficult.
Some of you would have
seen the movie called
"Ex Machina," where the entire
premise was around the Turing
test.
But if you think about it,
there was a computer program
called ELIZA.
Any of you have heard
of the computer program
called ELIZA in the '60s?
Yes.
And ELIZA proved to
me once and for all
that we pay too much money
paid to the psychiatrist,
the $1,000 an hour,
because all ELIZA had
to do on the other end
was respond back with,
if you said that
you're feeling down,
she would say, tell me
why you're feeling down.
And there goes your $1,000.
So it did appear
like a psychiatrist.
But we know for all that she was
actually not really doing much.
The contrast with AI,
really, is this concept
of IA, which has had a
much more profound impact
in our existence.
The concept of IA, or
intelligence amplification,
was brought about
by the people who
were doing cybernetics
in '50s and '60s
about machine and
human interaction.
And William Ross Ashby
actually coined the term,
where he said that
machines actually are there
to amplify human
intelligence, as opposed
to AI, whose goal it is
to actually figure out
whether machines can actually
substitute human intelligence.
And if you look at this entire
IT span, the evolution of IT
over the last 40 years,
a huge amount of it
has been in terms of
intelligence amplification, as
opposed to artificial
intelligence.
And what's happening is that
the hype, whether it's the hype
or whether it is the reality or
whether the fear of what else
is AI tends to dominate
the conversation.
But really it is AI and IA
that kind of go together.
To kind of bring
these things together,
if you think about
the Google car,
the Waymo car is a car
which says, doesn't even
have a steering wheel, does
not even have a steering wheel,
whereas Tesla, on
the other hand,
is there supporting the human
beings make better decisions.
Keep that in mind
as you kind of think
through all of this
discussion and technology
when it comes to all of this.
Now, what's interesting for
us, some of us geeks out there,
is irrespective whether
we talk about AI
or whether we talk about
IA, underneath all of it
is machine learning.
And what machine
learning really is,
it's all about bringing
the power of machines
to actually learn.
And the three facets that the
machines actually learn with,
and Fei-Fei brought out a
fourth one called talent,
but I'll ignore that for now.
We are all extremely
talented folks anyway,
so that's a given.
It's data, computation,
and computation
is shown as a calculator.
Don't know why.
And by the way, my
favorite calculator
is the HP calculator.
Anybody who talks to me
about any other calculator
is not going to go
anywhere with me.
And then algorithms.
So as you all think about
the power of AI, IA,
and machine learning,
think about what
is your currency that you have?
Do you have access to data?
Do you have access
to computation?
And do you have
access to algorithms?
And where you think that you
may be falling a bit short,
and if you really believe
at the end of this talk
that it's really, really
important for AI to play
a role in it, but you're falling
short on one of these three
dimensions, what
is your strategy
to actually kind of complement
and build yourself around it?
Now, in order for me to
kind of connect AI and APIs,
I thought I'll take you
through a journey of AI.
And the best way
to take a journey
is when human beings want to
pit themselves against machines.
Not ELIZA.
And human beings have
almost always decided--
not always decided,
have felt that one
of the tasks that they want
to compete with machines
is in playing games.
The routes are well-defined.
The winners and the losers
are clearly known at the end.
So why won't we play games?
So what I'm going to
do is kind of take you
through a journey of AI and its
technology through some games
that humans, in the form
of programming computation,
have played with
real human beings.
So some of you
remember Deep Blue.
IBM's Deep Blue computer beat,
in the rematch, Garry Kasparov.
And some of you may have
seen Garry's expressions.
He was not pleased.
But in reality,
people said, this
is the dawn of
machine intelligence.
No.
This was really
machine computation
beating human intelligence.
The rules of chess allowed
the Deep Blue machine--
I was at IBM at that time--
to look far enough in
advance and figure out what
is kind of the optimal move.
So this was not
machine intelligence.
And then, again
when I was at IBM,
those of you who remember
IBM Watson playing
against Ken Jennings and the
other person and winning,
and Ken Jennings at the end
saying, "I, for one, welcome
my machine overlords."
But for those of you who
saw that, if you remember,
Watson laid a giant turd
at the end of the game.
I don't know how many of you
remember, but for all of you,
I'll just kind of
bring it out for you.
The question was, name a US city
whose largest airport is named
after something that happened--
an important person
in World War II
and whose second-largest
airport is named
after a battle in World War II.
And guess what
Watson came up with?
Toronto.
Now, it probably ascribed
to an imperialistic vision
of taking over the world and
making Canada the 51st state
or whatever it was.
But you realize at
that very moment
that as intelligent
as computers can get,
they are as fallible
as human beings.
But what was interesting
was that was a step away
from just computation to
actually understanding
language.
And for those of you who
love to play "Jeopardy!",
understanding the
subtlety and puns
and everything else, and this
was definitely an advancement.
So we went from computation to
some amount of intelligence.
But what's really happening
in this world today
is that there's a whole ream
of new machine learning and AI
techniques that
are coming about.
And the most
promising of them is
what's called neural networks.
And neural networks try
to mimic human brains,
even though human
brains are made up
of trillions of connections,
whereas neural networks aren't,
and therefore they can
solve simpler problems.
But what neural
networks tried to do
is that there is an
interconnectivity
of computational bits, and you
give it an input on one side
and you tell it what
the output should be,
and the network then
learns by itself.
And what it does, the
kind of magic it does,
the steepest gradient descent,
I loved writing the go program
for a three-way neural
network and everything else
in order to kind of learn
what the heck was going on.
It kind of learns, and then
when you give it something new,
it is able to tell you
that this is a cat.
Now, this is in contrast with
how machine intelligence worked
in the past.
Machine intelligence
in the past,
you may have programmed a
rule in the end which said,
if that animal has whiskers
and shows an attitude,
then it's a cat.
If an animal has whiskers and
is very loving, then it's a dog.
Right?
I'm neither a cat
owner nor a dog owner,
so I probably offended
all sets of you.
But the essential
thing is that you are
kind of building these rules.
And those rules are
phenomenal, except they
really, really suck, right?
You cannot build those rules.
So in contrast, neural networks
are like this brain of ours
that some magic
happens, and we are
able to recognize
that that's a chair.
And we're able to recognize
who's a man and who's a woman.
How we're doing
that, we don't know.
So in some ways,
it is profoundly
dissatisfying,
profoundly dissatisfying
that this new branch
of machine intelligence
is not able to
explain to us how we
are reaching those conclusions.
But it's also
profoundly satisfying
that it can actually
solve a set of problems
that you couldn't solve before.
Neural networks have
come a long, long way.
They can recognize,
obviously, vision, speech,
complex constructs
that we have showed,
and languages and translations.
But that's all very
good, because what
neural networks says is that
you give it a set of data.
There are smart people
that say this is a cat
and this is a dog.
And neural networks determine
what's really going on.
What if you don't know?
What if you don't
have a training set?
What do you do?
So there's a new branch of
kind of machine intelligence
which is kind of--
one of those
branches is something
called reinforcement
learning, which
says that, throw the machine
in the wild and let it actually
figure out what's going on.
And that is kind
of the concept that
was then used in the
next game that machines
beat human beings.
And that was Go.
And if you play that
video, in the end,
just like Garry
Kasparov saying this,
just like Ken Jennings saying
we welcome our new overlords,
the Go master was kind of, whoa.
What is going on?
Now, in this particular
case, I don't play Go,
but Go is infinitely
more complex than chess,
and simple deep computation
does not solve the problem.
And Google's Deep Mind had to
bring reinforcement techniques,
reinforcement learning
techniques, in order
to be able to beat
the Go champion.
Now, quite recently,
machines have won on poker.
Now, you would think
that poker is easy.
For those of you
who are from India,
we play a thing
called [INAUDIBLE].
I can't play poker, so I
don't know what poker is.
But I'm assured that
it is infinitely more
complex than any game that we
could have played in India.
So, but what a computer program
called Libratus from CMU
managed to beat
the poker champion.
And it had three levels
of learning going on--
standard reinforcement,
standard programming,
reinforcement
learning based on what
it was observing during the day,
what the players were doing,
and then kind of
reprogramming at the night.
So human beings have
been able to program
the machines to beat other
human beings to play games.
And there have been strong
advancement that's going on.
Right now, there
are no machines that
can program machines
to beat human beings.
So it's safe for us.
We are all there.
We actually help make all
of these programs happen.
But the advancements
are happening
based on these new
clusters of techniques that
actually make a difference.
Now, what that means
is that beyond games--
games are interesting.
It's entertaining.
It's us versus them, and
we root for, depending
on which side we are, we
root for either machines
or human beings.
It's a phenomenal thing.
But machine learning is
making a huge difference
in a lot of other areas.
Fei-Fei touched on it.
In vision, machine learning
is making a big difference.
Now, what's very,
very interesting
about vision is that it is
not just machine learning that
makes a difference.
A lot of advancements in IT
happen when two or three forces
kind of come together.
And in this case, machine
learning combined with sensors
have actually helped really
advance a lot of this.
Robots are becoming
much, much smarter.
I don't know whether
any of you have ever
programmed in a programming
language called Forth.
Any raise of hands?
That's it, that distinguished
gentleman to my right.
And Forth was really designed
for helping kind of make moves.
But human beings were
completely in control.
And here, robots are kind
of learning themselves.
So the theme in all of this
is that the intelligence
has been used to power
either some interesting games
or some applications
that kind of bring
that intelligence to bear.
The next very, very important
trend that's happening,
and the trend that even
Fei-Fei talked about yesterday,
was this concept of
democratization of AI.
So AI was being built in the
context of either applications
that you didn't care about,
like games, or applications
that you cared about, like
vision and Street View.
But AI was being
built in context
of all of those applications.
What Google, as an example
here, has been doing
is to kind of
break that barrier,
break that barrier between
machine intelligence
and the applications, so that
now the applications actually
touch a lot more people.
And the common term that's
kind of being brought about
is this concept of
democratization of AI.
And this is the first place
where APIs make a difference.
The breaking of the barrier
between an application
and a capability below
it happens through APIs.
OK, great.
So that's what's
really happening.
So APIs are actually enabling
these specialized algorithms
to get embedded in a
lot more applications.
And this is where, now, when
you get to the industrial age
of AI, the impact will happen.
So it is not just the
intelligence and algorithms
built bespoke, but
applied across the board
that will make a difference.
So to give you some
examples, Google Photos
is just absolutely fantastic.
I have moved all my
stuff to Google Photos.
I don't have a dog out
there, but we typically,
when we are winding
down, Apigee,
we wanted to create a
workbook-- sorry, a photo book,
and I was able to kind of
search through the photos based
on finding people.
Translation, machine translation
is a very tough problem.
Some of you might
have seen the work
that Jeff Dean and
others did in order
to get machine translation
built on neural networks.
And it has just been astounding
how much progress machine
translation has built.
But how many of us
really care about reading
that original stuff
in Italian or Latin
and translating it into English?
But if you now think
about the application
of you are traveling and
you come across street signs
and you come across
subway signs,
how do you actually ensure that
the application that you're
dealing with has been
powered with intelligence?
So the break from
bespoke applications
to taking intelligence
and applying it everywhere
is happening through APIs.
Prabhakar talked about it.
He had kind of raised
the bar on the numbers.
He said one in eight.
I thought it was one in 10.
But for those people
who interact with
me know that at least 10% of
responses that they get from me
are machine-generated.
Now, the great thing is
they have no clue which one.
They have no clue which one.
But it's absolutely
mind-boggling
how good machine intelligence.
So there's another example of
how machine intelligence has
gotten democratized,
because now it is touching
people, everyday applications.
Search-- all of you use Search.
Search has phenomenal sets
of inputs associated with it.
When Larry and Sergey
built out Google,
they said that we are going to
build Search based on PageRank
so that it's not as important
as to how you say you are good.
It's how important how
others say you are good.
And PageRank then
turned out to be one
of the fundamental disruptors.
But over time, of course,
that is not the only signal.
And it turns out that
applying machine intelligence
and understanding user behavior
and others have really,
really helped improve
the search technology.
So the net of all
of it is that we
are reaching the era of not
only advancements in AI,
but taking those AI through APIs
and applying it to applications
that we all look,
touch, and feel.
And in that context,
in that context,
as for those of you who
work in enterprises,
think about the
problems that you
have today that would be better
solved if you could actually
take some amount of machine
intelligence and power
these classes of applications.
Right, so I'm not going to
walk you through all of it.
All of you have ideas
and thought processes
on what can be done.
But things that
you couldn't do can
be done because of
advancements in AI
and the ability to couple
that AI into the application
through APIs.
So the third part that I want
to just kind of talk about
is, this is great.
This is great.
Google and IBM and others
have done some innovation.
What's that got to
do with all of you?
So the third major thing
that I want to talk about
is that what's
really going on is
that one aspect or
democratization of AI
is that the AI
techniques are more
easily available for everyone.
So what Google has
done, for example,
it has put out this
thing called TensorFlow--
those of you who want to
kind of geekify on tensors,
we can have a
discussion afterwards--
has put out this thing called
TensorFlow so that all of you
can actually
leverage your smarts
against some infrastructure
that Google provides.
But in addition,
Google has started
to provide not just these
kind of raw building block
capabilities, which are shown
on the right, where you can
actually take those raw building
block capabilities and apply
your talent and do
the right things.
But they're starting to package
these kind of building blocks
with an API in front of
them so that you don't have
to worry about doing anything.
So on the left, I've shown kind
of these four building blocks.
Translation, if you really
care about translation,
send it a piece of
text through an API
and it will come
back translated.
Vision, send it an image.
Now, just think about it.
If you can send it
an image, you may
be able to actually
figure out what
the damage is for a
particular property,
if you are in
property insurance.
Speech, the major trend towards
creating interfaces in speech
are just text understanding.
So what's really happening is
that this AI, which started off
being driven by these
applications which
were somewhat esoteric, like
playing games, to applications
that required very tight
connection with AI,
those techniques
are now starting
to come out and be
available for all of you
in order to actually
make a difference.
So I've already kind of
touched on AI and APIs,
but I want to just
kind of give you
somewhat further discussions
on kind of this duality.
So what we have
talked about is how
AI will be deeply
affected by APIs,
which is AI gets unleashed
for the masses through APIs.
Obviously, as I said,
whether you take some machine
intelligence, whether you
write any of your machine
intelligence, but if
you really, really want
to power the myriads
of applications,
then you need that gearbox.
That's our gearbox for APIs.
You need that gearbox that will
take all of that intelligence
and power your applications.
Apigee has always been in the
business of decoupling services
with applications,
because you want
to make sure that the
innovation in the applications
happens at a rate that is
different than the innovation
in the services below it.
The innovation in AI
happened by coupling
of the applications and AI.
And now with APIs, this
barrier is breaking.
But there's a second very,
very fundamental thing
that's happening, is that
APIs are actually also
the way in which
data are flowing back
to make these machine
learning intelligence smarter.
So there's duality
between intelligence,
APIs to power applications
based on their intelligence,
and then APIs to deliver data
back for those intelligence,
is that virtuous cycle that we
actually see a lot happening.
But that duality is also true.
AI will deeply affect APIs.
So for those of you
who are writing APIs,
for those of you who
are writing APIs,
you need to think through
how AI will deeply affect
the APIs that you're writing.
So I'm going to
spend a few minutes
in kind of getting you to
think about your world of APIs
and to see how AI will actually
make a difference there.
So in order to do
that, I'm going
to actually blow past some
assumption that you have.
And what I want to do is
to get you a bit anxious
and think through and say, oh
my god, if the world is really
different, how I've
been thinking of APIs,
how will I think about
them differently?
So as a first example, I've
shown an industrial economy
and a smokestack.
So pardon me, but typically,
many of us, many of you
think of end consumers
as your customers.
What if you're wrong?
What if instead of you being
at the center of the universe
where people come to you
and get your services,
the thing is completely flipped?
What if, what if the consumer is
at the center of the universe,
and the consumer chooses, she
chooses to interact with you?
In that case, when
you're thinking
about your world of
interacting with that consumer,
how would you embed intelligence
into every interaction?
Because the person
chooses to come to you.
You don't choose them.
If that's the case--
and there's a
phenomenal piece of work
by a person called Nir Eyal
called "The Hook Framework"--
how would you actually
use intelligence
to hook that person, so that
among all the time that she
would spend with
you, she actually
gets most fun and most
interactions with you?
The world is not slowing down.
It is kind of slowing down.
I know that's true.
It's actually true.
We'll probably
add about a minute
to Earth's rotation in
the next million years.
But that's not sufficient to
actually create more time.
The world is not slowing
down, then how would
you actually hook the people
in order to actually do that?
And that's where
you got to think
about embedding AI into
every piece of interaction
that you do.
And if you believe that you do
the interaction through apps
that are connected
by APIs, you actually
have to embed AI into
every piece of interaction,
into every API.
What if you kept
thinking that AI
is for esoteric applications?
What if you thought
that AI is for games?
What if you thought that
AI is for diagnostics?
All great things.
But what if you thought that
AI is actually not going
to affect you in any deep way?
But in reality, if it is the
case that every application
needs to become a
learning application,
if every application needs
to actually adapt and learn,
what if that's the case?
The examples that I showed you.
Then you have to
embed intelligence
into every
application, every API.
So think about it.
As you think about
building your API layer,
building a new class of
applications, if you're not
going to actually embed
intelligence in that layer,
then you're going to
actually be left behind.
The third thing that
I want to talk about
is what if you thought that
your network ended on your four
walls?
That's what we typically
do, for those of us who
are in the enterprise world.
But in reality, what
if the network actually
extended everywhere?
There are no four walls.
The touch points,
the interactions,
all have moved to the edge.
Now you have to
embed intelligence
into every piece of the network.
The way to embed the
intelligence, of course,
is by taking your enterprise
capabilities through APIs.
But those, you have
got to actually power
and embed with AI.
You will embed intelligence
into your edge applications
for better operations, for
better customer interactions,
and for security.
So what I've tried to do over
these kind of three things
is to say that as you have
embarked upon your API journey
to create this kind
of digital world
in which many more
forms of interaction
is going to happen with you,
if you ignore the world of AI,
you're actually
going to be building
to the world of
yesterday, as opposed
to the world of tomorrow.
So instead of thinking
about, oh, the best I can do
is to actually just
connect my mobile app
to my back-end system, you
really have to think about,
how do you make that connection
to be smart, intelligent,
and secure?
So just as an example,
we provide you
with a product called
Apigee Edge that enables
you to build up those APIs.
And one of the things
that we're doing
is we are applying
machine intelligence so
that as you expose your
APIs through Apigee,
machine intelligence
can actually
help you detect when the
interactions that are coming in
are legitimate, and
when they are not.
But you have got to think
through every interaction
that's going on and seeing
how you can actually
leverage that power for
better interactions and better
security.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to call Jason Smith here,
who has been working in
this area of AI and API
for a long time, and he's
going to kind of walk you
through what they're
doing at rMark Bio.
And then I'll come
back and conclude.
Welcome, Jason.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON SMITH: Thank you.
I'm taking it off.
So I'm the co-founder
and CEO of rMark Bio,
and what we've set out to do
with artificial intelligence
is to leverage AI to help reduce
the inefficiencies in which
life science
companies-- for example,
pharmaceutical
companies-- can partner
with various researchers,
clinical partners,
and academic institutions
based on the various stages
of their drugs going
through development,
and ultimately, anyone in
the health care market.
So where we were at, we've
designed the blueprint
for really transforming
this global health care data
into business intelligence.
And this is really
important for what
we want to solve that's
different than what everyone
else has tried to do before,
because today, it's all
been about having
data scientists attack
the problem who do not speak
the language of the business,
or you have business
strategists saying,
we need these type of people,
and the data scientists don't
understand what
that fundamentally
means to go extract that
from all the global health
care data out there.
So the first thing
we knew we had
to do when we started this
project about two years ago was
we had to break
down the barriers.
We could build the coolest
platform in the world,
but if we couldn't
consistently get data in there,
it meant nothing.
Then, when we go
to our customers,
if we couldn't get their
data into our platform,
it meant nothing, because the
unique value that we wanted
to solve was that ability
to translate between data
and the business
needs in real time.
So our approach
that we've started
to go after was, how
do we create a platform
and then create APIs around each
one of these tiny little bits
so we can slowly,
over the few years,
build up a very large
platform of microservices
that we can leverage
independently
of each other based on
different customer needs?
So I think the best way
to walk through this
is I'll actually walk you
guys through an example
of a customer problem that
we've recently solved.
So a customer, a large
pharmaceutical company
came to us and said, look,
we've got all this clinical data
internally.
We have all this ongoing
R&D data going internally.
We also have all the global
health data you guys have.
What we don't
understand how to do
is to align that in
real time with who
we should be partnering with.
So we want to go to understand
that if we're going to roll out
a leukemia drug, or
we're going to roll out
a multiple sclerosis
drug, there's
certain places in the world
where these patients are highly
populated.
There's certain places in the
world where their competition's
already there.
And there's certain
places where their drug
is going to have higher
efficacy treating certain types
of patients than not.
They came to us to say,
help us understand how to,
A, pull all this data in.
Help us to understand
what this data really
means so we can go out and
create deeper engagement
strategies.
And then third, how
do we learn from it?
How do we get feedback?
Having rMark go in and survey
their people in the field,
saying, was that a
good recommendation?
Did you like the
person we recommended?
Did that align?
That's not going to work.
So we knew right away we had
to build in some mechanism
to receive data in a learning
model and learning information
back from our
customers in real time
who's actually out in the field.
So when we started
to engage in this,
we have our global
health data that we
pull in from every night
from all over the world.
We quickly realized that these
pharmaceutical companies,
despite being inside
the four walls,
actually have the exact
same problem, where
their data is highly siloed.
So you have omics data.
So this is genetics,
genomics, proteomics,
people who are actually running
the real science out there
at the fundamental target level.
You actually have the internal
drug data, all their data
through the FDA process,
what they went through,
the reports they cited,
everything of that nature.
They have practitioner
databases, what's
happening in the industry.
I have databases
from IMS and others
about what practitioners
are actually doing
and who they're targeting
and who they're helping.
But that sits
completely isolated.
Again, insurance data, and
then they have research data.
They have teams of people
going out there and pulling
in all this global health care
data, but it's sitting siloed,
and any of the machine
learning and any
of the analytics on this is
completely separate from all
these other groups.
So in our conversations,
we quickly
found that data was really
problematic for them.
First, they have the three V's.
They just cannot handle the
size and the change in which
the data comes in.
Then, based on those silos,
how do they even exchange it?
How do they share it?
What do they want to do with it?
They're not even sure
what questions to ask.
So they had no really idea how
to draw insights across all
these different data silos.
And then once you have
that, how do you translate
that in real time to, I need a
team to go to Washington State
and find these
five practitioners
and engage with them, because
we need their clinical studies?
And then most importantly,
AI was problematic.
We found great data
scientists internally,
but were really isolated
to their specialty.
So they understood omics.
They understood how to
parse a grant paper.
They understood how to apply NLP
to a PubMed document on scale.
But they didn't quite
know how to translate
that skill set to other
data sets and other teams
within the organization.
And fundamentally,
they were spending
a lot of time and money doing
very large-scale partnerships
to try to solve this problem.
And there were, at the end
the day, missed consequences.
When you have trouble with the
data, you have trouble with AI,
we're having missed
consequences.
They're missing opportunities.
They're spending a
lot of time and money,
and most importantly,
by the time
they get done with one
subset of analysis,
they had to go back and
do it all over again.
So our approach was, OK, we can
apply artificial intelligence
to solve a lot of this.
And Anant took us on
a nice game journey.
This is going to
be a little drier.
be how we actually
took the approach
with them, and how
we leveraged some of
the Apigee systems
and then ultimately some of the
Google technologies for this.
So the first thing we
knew we had to do on scale
and build microservices around
and created an API that we
could reuse every single
time to get this data
was to ingest all this
global health care data
every single night,
normalize it, and prep it
for future analysis.
Then, once we had that, we
had to start building learning
models.
We will talk about this
a little bit later,
but we leveraged TensorFlow.
We leveraged some internal
algorithms that we developed
for our deep learning platform.
We have to start taking
this data in and letting
the system understand
what it is and learn.
Next, we had to get
our customer data.
Now, this is where the
real challenge was.
As I discussed, there's multiple
silos across multiple business
and technology divisions.
There's also just silos
within the technology.
Very often, when you go into
very large scale enterprises
that have been
around for 80 years,
you're going to have
data systems that
aren't readily available.
It's not all going to
be a node database,
or it's not going to be just
up on Datastore, Couchbase,
and JSON, which is
really nice and easy.
It's going to be
something a little gnarly,
that you got to figure
out, what do I actually
need to get out of
here and how do I even
access the systems
behind IT firewalls
in a highly-regulated system?
And then ultimately, as a
business, this is great.
We can do this one time.
We have to figure out how to
create a platform that I can
open up to not only ourselves
for our applications,
but we can't build
every application
in the world for every customer.
We want them eventually to
be empowered to take our APIs
and take our platform and
build their own applications,
integrate it deeper
at different points
within the tools they use.
We're not the ones
always doing it.
So the first one was
store and gather,
or gather and store, actually.
So for this, we went around.
We created a series of
microservices using the Apigee
platform for our
APIs using Edge that
talked to these individual
behind-the-scenes data sources.
So we were able to start
pulling in the data,
ingesting it, understanding it.
For us, we used DataProc
just for the volume.
I don't know how many of you
here have used that before.
We love it.
We're huge fans of it,
coming over from Spark
and not having to manage
all that ourselves.
And then we've recently
started engaging
with Cloud Functions,
where that's
been helping a lot with just
the onset scale of data,
because customers are
constantly updating.
They have data that's changing.
They're running hundreds
and thousands of experiments
a month at times.
They have people in the
constantly field learning
new things, and
we have to ingest
all that in real time, plus
all the global health data.
And then storage.
Where do we store this data?
For this particular project,
we leveraged Cloud Store
and Data Store, because
of the nature for the data
and that it made the
most sense for how
we were going to post-process
it for our platform.
So then next after this,
we have the data in there.
We start looking at
where are the models.
So we're big fans of TensorFlow.
A lot of our core
matrices algorithms run,
so TensorFlow has
a nice alignment
with where we were
kind of headed
with some SVD and other
techniques we're leveraging.
And then just some of the
natural language processing.
We do still have to pull out key
concepts, key words, sentiment.
We know from pulling in from
Salesforce data in real time,
if someone is out in the
field and spoke to a doctor
and they hear about these
new patients they have,
that have the rare
disease, we can
ingest that in real time,
flag that, and push that out,
so someone in the business team
can make a real-time decision
off of that information.
And then how do we put
services around it?
So if I walked into my customers
and said, here's all the data,
and here's 42 different
microservices and 50 APIs,
that's not going to solve it.
We had to bundle this
up into API packages
that they could use
and they could access
and they felt were
secure, most importantly,
because at the end
of all this, we're
in a highly-regulated industry
that requires, if nothing else,
discretion and security
first and foremost.
So we built three primary
services for our customer
on this particular project,
on top of our platform.
One was the real-time
recommendations.
So this is our
learning process that
understands who to recommend
to the people in the field.
So for example, if you're a
top-10 pharmaceutical company,
you have anywhere between
500 and 2,000 people
you employ that go out
all around the world.
Their entire job
is to find people
to partner with, either doctors,
either academic researchers,
maybe more strategic as
an entire institution.
This is all they do.
And it's a very manual
labor intensive.
This service bifurcates
that manual process for them
to a large degree, where
we can give them real-time
recommendations about what's
happening in the field that
they're in--
a therapeutic area, in
a regional location--
that aligns with their
global business strategies.
Learning and feedback.
So Anant made a great point,
and we couldn't agree more.
None of this matters if
it's all push, if you don't
start pulling, and letting
the data reinforce and train
our models for us, not from
instant thumbs up, thumbs down.
It's got to be deeper than that.
So we need to look at everything
from when we integrate
with Salesforce, we
integrate with Viva,
we integrate with a
myriad of applications.
Our customers, users,
touch every single day,
and their employees
touch every single day.
We need to be able to bring
all that in, and automatically
continue to train
our models such
that we can leverage this by
the real-time recommendations
and by the clinical insight
service, which normally we'd
never talk to each other.
Those services never
talk to each other.
But because we're getting that
constant feedback from them,
we're giving that constant,
hey, I like this person.
I don't like this person.
But we're not asking them that.
We're able to interpret that.
We can provide that
through our APIs
back to the real-time
recommendations,
back to our clinical insights
model, through the APIs.
And now we're training
three models in parallel
through this platform.
And then ultimately, Edge.
Edge is the way we push it out.
So as I mentioned
earlier, Edge provided us
with the fundamental
infrastructure, the security,
and the deployment stability
that we needed from Apigee
to allow our customers to feel
safe, embed this API into some
of their existing applications.
In this particular
case, we actually
built a one-off custom app
for them on top of our APIs.
They embedded it in Salesforce
and another proprietary tool
they had in-house.
So now, all through Edge, we
have our app using these APIs
that their employees
are using, and all
these other third-party
applications
are now accessing it
through the Edge platform.
So essentially, we set out to
solve a fairly large problem
in this space.
And we think we are.
We think we're headed
in the right direction.
And ultimately, it comes down
to putting lots of intelligence
behind every little piece
along the way of the pipeline
and exposing that
through APIs such
that we don't have to solve
all the problems today.
I don't have to have every
data source integrated today.
learning model figured out
today.
I don't have to have every
need of my customer figured out
today.
I can stitch and
build these as I go.
I can modify my models.
I can modify my ingest.
And done correctly, I
don't have to modify
a lot of my interfaces.
And when I do, I've got Edge
to help me migrate my customers
from my internal platform.
So we don't just use
Edge for our customers.
We actually use this for all
of our internal microservices
all the way through
the platform, which
now is somewhere in the
neighborhood of about
25 different microservices
that we just consume internally
long before we even
get to our customer.
Thank you.
ANANT JHINGRAN: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
This thing is heavy if
it is not clipped in.
Thank you so much.
OK.
So what we have done
is we have kind of--
I talked a bit about
this advancement of AI
and how it's gone from
siloed applications
to being democratized
through APIs.
We talked about how, if you
are embarking on an API journey
by itself, you got
to think about AI
as powering all of
the interactions that
are enabled by APIs.
And then Jason talked through
a wonderful set of examples
of how, in the area that he's
in, APIs enable better AI,
and then AI enables
better APIs, and there
is this kind of feedback
loop that's going on.
And for those of
you who are kind
of thinking through live
example of AI being applied,
just look at the
two blue screens
on the left and the right.
And there's nobody sitting
out there transcribing.
This is all going on by
speech-to-text translations
and others that are going on.
So this is the fundamental
point that we have
tried to make in this thing.
But I want to just
step back a bit
and say that if you
really want to embark
on an AI and an
API-driven journey,
technology will be easy.
The reason technology
is easy is because there
are enough
advancements happening
and they are being released
out in the wild for you
to actually make use of.
What you all have
to think through
is the people aspect of it.
Other day I read
something which said,
or every doctor will have
to become a data scientist.
I said, what the heck
is going on here?
Right?
And then tons of people did
thumbs up, thumbs up on it.
Wow, sounded really,
really interesting.
Every doctor.
The doctor barely has
time to look after you.
Do you think that she
has time to actually
now become a data scientist?
That's not going to happen.
But what's really
going to happen
is that you have to
think through how
your developers start leveraging
the work of data scientists.
You have got to think
about how you're
going to disaggregate your
machine intelligence and AI
organizations and scatter
them into the rest
of your organization.
Ken Rudin, who was
the CTO for Zynga
before he went to
Facebook, Ken Rudin
said that he actually took his
analytics and intelligence team
and broke it apart
and embedded it
into every team that
was building games,
because it was easy for
that team to come together,
but it was very difficult
for the developers
to actively think about
data and intelligence.
So as you think
about the role of AI,
as you think about the
impact of AI and APIs
and the duality of
it, think about some
of the organization
structures that
are fundamentally important.
But the most important thing for
you is the theme that I always
like to say, is we have--
in the world of APIs, we
used to say, adapt or die.
Sounds dangerous.
I say adopt AI or die.
So thank you very much, folks.
And we have got some time for
questions, if you all have.
And Jason, come on up.
And let's see if there
are any questions.
Otherwise, we'll be on our way.
Going once?
Twice?
Thrice?
Please, OK.
Can you either use a mic
or all of you wait for my--
OK, go ahead and say the
question, then I'll--
AUDIENCE: Jason, how do
you monetize your business?
What's your engagement
model with your clients?
ANANT JHINGRAN: Repeat.
JASON SMITH: Yeah,
so the question was
how do we monetize our
business and what's
our engagement model
with our clients?
So we have a--
it's essentially an
upfront license fee
and an ongoing monthly fee
for insights and services.
Traditionally, think of
it as enterprise SaaS
as our primary right now.
Over time, we'll have lower
costs for smaller companies.
We're primarily focused
on larger players now,
so our pharmaceutical partners,
our partnering with groups
like University of Chicago and
some other investment firms,
because that's really
the hands-on piece right
now that we're involved with.
ANANT JHINGRAN: OK.
OK, great, guys.
Thank you very, very much.
And we are around
for some time in case
you guys want to have questions.
But otherwise,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]